[موسيقى]
لدينا ابتسامات أو ربما فاجأنا ،
فما هو الدهر هو نوع جديد من
الكائن الافتراضي الذي يبدو مائة شخص
حقيقيًا يتصرف مثل الإنسان ، لكننا نحسب فقط
خارجيًا في
المساعد العادي ، لا يشبه
nyan مذكراتك العزيزة  الذي تتحدث إليه هو
صديقك الذي تبني معه ذاكرتك
وما هي حالات الاستخدام لشيء
مثل تلك الحالات ، يمكن أن
يكون مستشارك المالي التالي
موظف استقبال في الفندق ، يمكن أن يكون مجرد
صديق وماذا يعني ذلك بالنسبة  وظائف
ثم لم يتم إنشاء النيون لتحل محل
الوظائف البشرية ، تم إنشاء Neos للمساعدة
حيث لا يستطيع البشر الوصول إلى
حواجز اللغة ويمكن أن يكون النيون طبيبنا
أكثر من الأماكن التي لا يستطيع الطبيب الوصول إليها
[الموسيقى]
لذا سأطلب منها أن تقول القليل  عبارات
بلغات مختلفة ربما شيء من هذا القبيل في
الوقت الحالي ليس لديه أي ذكاء
في حد ذاته يتصرفون بذكاء ولكن
ليس لديهم مفهوم
لتعلم أطياف الذاكرة سوف
يجلب لغز التعلم  قد أكون
خطيرًا ،
هناك دائمًا سلع وسيئة من أي
تقنيات كيف نستخدمها
اليوم أو يفعلها شخص ما غدًا إذا
فعلنا ذلك اليوم ، نريد التأكد من أنه
من الألف إلى الياء من مستوى الهندسة
من مستوى التصميم  ليس
سوء استخدام